hello [ __ ] Wow wake up are you woken
up alright P headphone users first off
we're gonna take some roll call really
quick before we begin the episode well
we got my name is Gina and we're gonna
be talking about China's my name is
Nicki we're gonna be talking about birth
control
my name is tiff and we're I'm just here
my name is the lines really
self-conscious about her list because of
Islay but nobody else can really okay
that time putting on a character it's
not that bad but like sometimes I can
hear it this invisalign character is
evolving over each episode a lot work
there's nerd fetishes I will probably
love this you think so yeah oh my god
yeah so today we're gonna be talking
about birth control which has been a
topic that was heavily requested in the
comments section and also hormones and
overall female reproductive health
that sounds so textbook so like Anatomy
we're gonna be talking about female
reproductive health
we are not scientists we're gonna teach
how to cure your [ __ ] expert topic
we're not experts but we have vaginas
and we'd like to tell you about tell you
about our experience they have havin
vagina turned in so many people on ok so
when it comes to birth control I was
surprised to learn that not every state
even allows that to be taught in school
like Wow options are abstinence or
you're having sex for procreation really
like a red state blue space I think I
think so maybe I don't want to speak too
much on that cuz I don't really know the
exact reasons but I know state votes on
it and then a lot of jury learn about it
dude no but I'm also just thinking about
how many guys listen to our podcast and
about how like their girlfriend might be
about to get birth control and he's like
you know a lot of states don't I do and
he was like throwing out opinion
how to educate herself on a robot hot
right I have a guy who like cared about
what birth control I was seeking it was
asking me questions rather than can I
come in it like I was coming it brings
your pamphlets and [ __ ] from Planned
[Laughter]
Parenthood they they just tell you what
kinds there are I feel like they didn't
really yeah they don't tell you like
what happens from it how it messes with
your hormones did you guys ever put the
condom on the banana no did not no no
didn't watch a video of site did
anything I was curious I feel like that
these show didn't chose a lot yeah yeah
I was like is that really a thing he
shows I well I guess I did they did have
a condom and they did show us like the
proper way to roll it out to like have
it be the right way and also to leave
enough room in the tip so that like when
the guy comes it doesn't break the
condom yeah but that's that's it you
gotta have it like a sombrero i I think
that might have been taught like maybe
like 80s 90s 70s who knows whatever but
I I think the issue there was not that
the teenagers didn't know how to put
them on it was the teenagers they were
not wearing them take my Invisalign out
I need someone with no I just instead of
pulling off your earrings and popping
off before she can clearly guess she was
only wearing their lowers oh we're gonna
make Bruce oppose a purgative now damn
it do that it made me take my teeth out
yeah so when all of us here have been on
birth control when did you first start
taking it and what did you start taking
my first birth control I was I started
taking it when I was a virgin I didn't
have sex yet because I was trying to be
extra careful which is very ironic
because I ended up getting pregnant at
17 but it wasn't an end but it was
planned it was a plan pregnant a lot of
people don't know I was crazy when
you're 17 what are you thinking but no
you're just Mexican and they're very
they're like they just ignore birth
control together even if you take it you
know my first birth control method was
using the patch mmm and so I loved it
because you just had to wear it on just
once a month I think I forgot it was a
long time ago but I was like 15 when I
had it and and then I stopped taking
that or using it because there were
these infomercials at the time that they
were like have you been a victim of the
orth or ever patch make sure all 1-800
whatever and I'm like people are getting
sick from there like there's something
wrong with these things and because of
those infomercials I stopped using it
and then I went to my doctor to try to
get those pills so how old were you I
was 16 so you went to a doctor that seen
60 yeah and one of those free clinics
okay yeah so if you're out there
listening and maybe you're younger and
you're thinking about going on birth
control definitely talk to a doctor or
like go set up an appointment with
gynecologists to get birth control is
that way you can get birth control
without Parenthood which they have
people there that kid they're allowed to
give you birth control but I felt like
the way I got it
I was trying to not let my parents know
that I wanted to have sex and I didn't
want them to know as taking birth
control and so that's what it's there
for is so everyone can be protected even
if you're too scared to tell your
parents yeah but I feel like the dose
they put me on because they didn't
measure anything I had no prior
experience it was way too high hormone
only for me and I ended up going crazy
and trying to crash my car into a tree
oh my god but that's a whole spread on
Oh stories to come from a B to a D and
it was so sensitive that you couldn't
touch them so my boyfriend were like try
to touch them I'm back go that's like it
worked all to plan to give you size D
and then if you crash your car you
already have airbags you know they were
blended how about you both I I did not
start taking birth control until I was
26 maybe I when I was a lot younger and
like for anyone that has like really bad
acne or cystic acne I've had cystic acne
since I was like 13 and I went to ice
level Lisp I went to the doctor and my
doctor was like oh we need to put it on
birth control like to help with the acne
and my mom was so afraid of me having
sex that she did not put me on the birth
control and you know Here I am ten years
later I have like really you guys are
gonna say I said that bad but I have
acne scarring on my face from cystic
acne and I wish that I had cleared this
up years earlier so that's just kind of
like my own personal message for like
moms when you know that comes up for
your child or for anyone else that's you
know that age that is suffering from
that I had cystic acne right up until 26
when I got on birth control yeah I got
on birth control and it cleared my face
up like you see this yeah nothing yeah
people don't realize that birth control
isn't just a baby baby it actually does
[ __ ] for you it balances your body out a
lot of times and your mood I and I'm not
I I don't know if it was this way for I
would mean Nikki you said that it kind
of made you a little more loopy but like
for me personally it started to level
out my mood because you got on the right
one yeah so when I got on the right one
it totally leveled my mood I didn't have
any cravings my breasts weren't tender
anymore out what was the RISM I told him
I called my mom crying when I was about
to crash my car to a dream confessed to
her that I had been taking birth control
that was the only thing different my
because I was it was I felt crazy how
long were you on that probably like
three months three months or something
like that maybe a little bit longer but
like four months um and she took me to
made an appointment book
and took me to a doctor to get it
switched and the new one that they put
me on it was a much lower dose of some
hormone I can t remember what the one
was but same thing beause i had cystic
acne and it went away
I didn't even relate it till the birth
control I just thought it I grew out of
that phase until I got off birth control
when I was 29 and it all came back real
and I was like what I thought it just
went away with age but no it was totally
the hormones that that did that Wow
but Gina when did you what did you go on
[Laughter]
oh god I remember I think I started
going on it when I was about 18 and the
first time I ever went on it I went to
Planned Parenthood honestly you know
shout out to Planned Parenthood yeah
like as a young broke teenager Planned
Parenthood [ __ ] saved my life and
they give you free condoms free condoms
like everything that you need but I got
on the pill just a regular pill and it
worked fine for me but the thing is I'm
[ __ ] stupid and I forget my pill all
the time and I can't risk that anymore
yeah
so then I hopped on to Oh
on the pill I actually didn't have any
side effects at all so I kind of like
now I know that works for me and then I
went to the patch but the thing was I
was modeling at the time and the patch
is Lisa like the limp yeah like a black
yeah yes I kept on popping off during my
shoots and then leave like this gross
square so I couldn't do that anymore and
then as of recently I was actually for
like for three years I was there's an
arm implant so yeah birth control at the
implant into your arm and it's like the
size for all my ravers out there do you
guys my mother tiny tiny little sticks
that used to put in your mouth oh yeah
yeah and you would go to parties and not
do drugs so it's that small and they
would implant it into your arm but I got
[ __ ] like do so that thing laughs
that's what so four for three years I
had it in and I was like oh this is cool
like it's just in and I don't have to
worry about it I want to forget about
whatever it's fine
and then I
realizes I was starting to gain weight
yeah and I at first like for some reason
I didn't realize it was my birth control
for three years I gained like 20 pounds
wait was it wind up with the birth
control in ten pounds 750 pounds yeah
Wow and I was like oh for some reason I
had never associated it I was like oh
maybe it's just cuz I'm eating bad or
like whatever but after a while I was
like I started thinking about was like
oh [ __ ] it's my birth control and so at
this point right now so I got it out
recently and I'm at the heaviest I've
ever been like I'm still trying to lose
that weight I'm down ten so far yeah
good job thank you
so I realize like oh [ __ ] that's right
birth control makes you gain weight cuz
I never experienced that I was the
opposite though I was the opposite off
birth control is when I'm the happiest
I've ever been ever got I just went down
fifteen pounds but when I realized it
was because of that but I was taking
care of myself
improperly and speaking of care of we
have a sponsor
shout out to Kara's for sponsoring this
episode okay so you guys know that I'm
unhealthy I never drink water I don't
ever do [ __ ] for my health so care of is
basically a vitamin packet and
supplement packet that you can get after
taking a quiz on their website and it's
really cute like it's a really cute
little quiz where you can talk about or
you can answer questions about what you
want to take care of so like your hair
your sleep schedule your immunity and
stuff like that and you take a little
like just a little survey and they put
together a packet of vitamins for you
that you take every day and it's in like
a cute little package that you take out
every day and on the little package
there's like little questions like how's
your day today or what if you had like a
random fact yeah random stuff like that
remind says like good morning Beau's all
flirting with you but it's really easy
and convenient it's a daily vitamin
supplement packs it's customized for you
and oh and my favorite part about it is
that the packaging is it's a what is it
like the green like it's a eco-friendly
there yeah compostable compostable we
just made up word and I think it's I
don't know I think it
it's a real word and like it'll give you
a chance to your place I learned about
it that it makes your pee bright yellow
or 25% off your first care of order go
to take care of comm and enter b tch
exclamation point once again for 25 off
yo I'm dumb it's just right there like
you can't put it there man I have no
control you tell me what to do on a
paper I can do it dude you can tell me
to punch myself in the face right now
feds are in a promo code so for 25% off
your first care of order gonna take care
of dot-com and put in the code b tch to
get yourself healthy
once again that's 25% off your first
care of order go to take care of comm
and enter code b tch
25% I already have superpowers from it
I'm just letting you guys know
nice yeah you're awake you're here
before noon Thank You D Thank You Cara
all right back to birth control so TIFF
and I had the opposite experience of
gaining weight after we got off of it
did you ever like associ because I
didn't even associate it with birth
control for a while neither did I no but
you know because I did want to mention
cuz you were saying that you were on the
pills and that worked for you the pills
when I got off the patch I ended up
going back to the clinic and taking the
pills because I got scared of that
infomercial and then I realized that the
pills that the doctor gave me it gave me
my period twice in one month I was like
why would I why would anyone want this I
I stopped taking them and when I was in
between birth control that's when you
know Isaac's dad was like hey how about
we have a baby and I'm like alright and
then that's when I got pregnant it was
because I was in between Wow as well but
ovaries really capitalized on that
yeah time yeah yep yeah yeah um but yeah
the whole weekend thing I so after
having Isaac I ended up using the Mirena
the IUD and it's a five-year look it's
like it's shaped like a tee and it goes
into like your cervix of your uterus and
it releases hormones and it kind of the
way they explained it to me and I don't
know if this is still correct but they
said that it kind of tricks your body
into thinking you have the same hormones
as when you're pregnant so you don't
necessarily have periods anymore and
that actually affected my mood a lot I
was on that for 10 years so I had to I
you DS because I would change them and
that made me feel really like I was
really irritable like extra irritable
and I think I really am but that was
like such a huge chunk of my life so I
ended up thinking like am i yeah like is
this really just me but after taking it
out like I don't feel as irritable
anymore I definitely I have now had a
regular appetite because I think it was
affecting my appetite as well because I
wasn't gaining weight at all like I was
just forever under a hundred pounds like
I wanted to donate blood and I could
never make it to 109 pounds yeah and
then now I'm 120 where I'm like oh oh my
god what's happening but yes because of
the birth control ever since taking it
out now I have a regular appetite and
that so that means I'm finishing the
food on my plate and now I'm gaining
weight and I'm like whoa they got birth
control really affects you yeah dude I
had a I took or have you guys ever used
the ring there's a person too already
nuvaring then you've heard of it yeah
that [ __ ] made me the unfor Gnaeus
[ __ ] ever like I couldn't even
draw a dick photo and I had a boyfriend
and time and I'm just like I never
wanted to have sex and it dries you up
like crazy Wow I was like what is wrong
with me I can't even make a dirty joke
and I realize it was that yeah I think
it's a distribution of hormones because
you know you have testosterone and
estrogen and progesterone and if
everybody's different and everybody's
body needs a certain balance to like be
the right the correct flow of things and
that's what happened to me now with the
NuvaRing but with that first birth
control pill that I was on is it like I
couldn't get horny
I was like dried up I gained weight on
my stomach but also my boobs so it kind
of balanced out but they were super
sensitive and then I felt crazy like
irritable like I snapped it was like
constant PMS times ten yeah and it's
just fascinating like how much hormones
I don't think they teach you this like
nobody taught me that hormones play a
role in use of course I took
responsibility for me being a [ __ ] I
was like I guess I'm just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right now and it's that's not fair
because like hormones really it's a
chemical imbalance
ya know same thing as other chemical
imbalances like depression and other
things were it really [ __ ] with your
mental state and like your ability to
make judgments which was why I wanted to
run my car into a tree and it can affect
a lot and I was just working with my
dietitian about how it also affects your
digestive health and how it's hard to
like a lot of men or like if you work
with a personal trainer they they're try
to approach your weight loss like how
they do with other men and they don't
take into account how much hormones play
a role in women's health I think too
because they do really steroids well
yeah not only that but like just even if
they're not taking steroids I don't know
if it's been scientifically proven but I
I feel like guys have their man periods
- yeah it'll be a week out of the month
where they're just they're not
themselves and they have a cycle for
sure why why are you being like this I
heard you guys have a period - man it's
not just us yeah I think my worst
experience I actually texted the group
chat about this you guys remember when I
text you guys [ __ ] sobbing my eyes
out I can't taking it out oh yeah
taking out how do they take it out bro
so okay so the way they put it in is
like this big needle the numbing out is
this big needle think of it like a
tampon and you shove it in there and
then the needle out like that sighs no I
mean like the needles big oh yeah yeah
but the dummy a-- so the bruising is
[ __ ] wild afterwards Wow but so I
decided to take it out right how long
was it in three years okay I got so
chubby so and so I went to the doctor I
found this gynecologist and I went to
her and she like takes it out right so
how they do it is they make a little
incision on your arm and then off your
jacket yeah if you're on YouTube yeah
so like they make a cut there and they
kind of just like wiggle like they move
it in there around so till it pops out
great huh it's like an alien movie yeah
right and it was supposed to be a really
easy like five-minute procedure and um
so she she numbed me out and she cut me
open and no lie I can handle pain really
well like I've had stitches on my scalp
I'm fine you've had huge dicks yeah so
instead of like wiggling in Allegan
would not come out so she went in there
with like these plants like pliers and
she started wiggling around in there oh
yeah we and I'm trying my heart I
suppose like gee this sucks
and finally she dug in so deep and
wiggled so deep that it like shook me
like it hurts so bad that I screamed and
I don't you know I'm fine with pain but
it was like I screamed and it was
instant tears I was sobbing my eyes yeah
worst pain I've ever felt in my life
because she must be like going into the
muscle oh yeah they like with pliers
from the rest of what you told me in the
way that or told us and the way that she
was acting I feel like she should not be
a doctor I don't think so either and so
that should not be the typical
experience oh so like she was digging in
there and I swear this woman was like
ripping off my arm it was like this
sharp pain and burning maybe she's a
sadist right and then I was she looking
you directly in the eye well she was I
was like looking at the ceiling just
like sobbing my eyes out and so she's
like oh yeah I can't find it you have a
lot of like tissue around it whatever do
you want more lidocaine I'm like yeah
whatever just give me [ __ ] more she
put in another thing of lidocaine and I
can still feel oh it was so bad and like
it felt like she was kind of my arm off
um and then right when I like I just
really couldn't take it like I was I
told her I was like look maybe we should
do this another day she goes oh I got it
I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah so I'm just
like what the [ __ ] and then so I'm and I
told her I was like I'm gonna need a
second in this room because I'm like
yeah right that's traumatization yeah
fine let's take it take your time and
she doesn't tell me any aftercare like
usually after you go to a doctor with
especially procedures like that they
tell you how to take care of it and
your paper and she's all she said was
okay don't get it what I'm just like
what the [ __ ] dude and then like I'm
sitting there sobbing and she doesn't
even care she gives me I'll papers and
then it's like I had I was so upset that
I had to call my dad like dad yeah I
this is the most pain I've ever been in
in my life
like God never felt pain like this
before horrible I have a horror story to
it you know my birth control that yeah
that I UD it was the second one so I had
already experienced what it was like
taking out the first IUD and it wasn't
that bad it just feels like a little
like pinch in your uterus area so it
sounds crazy it's like having a cramp
like a period crap hmm and and so but
this time when she was trying to remove
it I guess what happened is the string
that they're supposed to use to pull out
the IUD that string had coiled up and
like some of the the meat or whatever it
like kind of went over you like your
flesh kind of rounded over I I don't
know why but I said this in Spanish in
my head which I don't even speak Spanish
anymore but gotten a like flesh is
gotten and it's the same word as meat
and haman Vietnamese - yeah that's why I
said meat but anyway so so then like it
just kind of yeah the flesh over and it
was the most painful thing ever I felt
like I had to give birth to this [ __ ]
IUD and it got so bad to the point where
she was telling me that you know if
we're not able to take it out today that
I'm gonna have to book you for a surgery
oh my god surgically remove it and I was
just like good they're just good it out
I don't want to pay extra because my
insurance sucks
yeah like another thing yeah so I'm like
no no no no you need to get it out so
then she try it she's like okay which
this is the last time I'm gonna try it
in the ship finally she pulls it out and
it felt like my uterus was coming with
her it was so painful but you see how
hard yeah just not get pregnant I never
[ __ ] yeah having a baby just trying to
[ __ ] without a condom yeah filled with
commies I don't
okay everyone is a cream pie every once
in a while takes like thoughts on the
male birth control thing yeah so that's
what I'm pissed about and okay there's a
lot of controversy here I'm sure I'm
gonna get corrected tenfold in the
comments but the articles that I was
reading they did a focus group on 300
men taking this new birth control pill
for men and they decided not to release
it to the public and then it needs
further testing because 20% of those men
experienced headaches Wow bill and stop
taking it I remember that article you're
correct yeah maybe this article was
meant to incite anger because it's
certain yeah but you know for women we
have to try all these different birth
control pills because sometimes people
can't be on the pill sometimes they have
to be on other things because it sort of
is that they have a million different
ways for a woman to have birth control
yeah do only a condom for the dudes you
got and the dudes everyone we don't want
you to wear condoms like the condoms
aren't fun for anyone but they are there
for a purpose
it's to they got a headache well this
[ __ ] tried to ram her car into a tree
like pretty sure you can handle a
[ __ ] headache pile and then some
people you know they get ovarian cysts
from the pill that's why it's really
important to check with your doctor
before getting on any sort of birth
control
I heard um I heard someone say like it's
better to unload the gun aka the dick
than shoot at a bulletproof vest you
know like and I like that more you know
cuz I like this [ __ ] sucks for us you
can handle a headache if you want a nut
in me okay yeah I wouldn't nuttin me
take a headache a headache
yeah the other method is a vasectomy but
and it's reversible yeah do you know how
many people I've met that do not
understand how the second ways work
dudes grown-ass dudes think a vasectomy
means he can never come again that are
you like you're 25 years old cuz I was
like you're 25 years old and this is how
you think of a second me [ __ ] works
for those of you don't know a vasectomy
means you're still coming you like
you're still shooting [ __ ] out but
they're just not swimmers they don't
they don't get you pregnant you can
still come yeah
so many people do not get that there's
no little spermies in their email semen
is the fluid that's what you want to see
it ego is so fragile right a jewel
fragile right and speaking of let's talk
about style I want to talk about style
because you know medication you want to
get semen on your shirt and you're like
oh no I don't know the style of shirt I
want so stitch fixes are sponsored today
and it's an online personal styling
service but for not the cost of like
your own personal stylist which is
really cool so I've had this for a
number of years now it's really neat how
they let they have you take a survey at
first and they kind of show you pictures
and you click the one that you're most
drawn to and they do they find your
style based off of the answers that you
chose and so at the end of the survey
they're like okay we think we got you we
think you got we got your style nailed
down they hook you up with your personal
stylist who you can exchange messages
with she'll ask you or he will ask you
hey do you want me to pick stuff out for
you or do you have like a special event
coming up what's what's the deal you
need some specific items in your
wardrobe and then you answer those
questions sometimes you just want to
surprise and then you just get a box
that shows up at your door and it's all
the stuff you love you get to try on
those clothes you get to see if they fit
you right you get to like do a little
twirly and your bathroom here or like
your full your full-length mirror you
look at different lighting take some
pictures different angles and then you
keep what you love and then you send the
rest back and basically there's a
styling fee that's $20 it just gets
deducted from whatever you purchased so
be cool I need that because I I struggle
with like color and I've only been
wearing all black so I wanted I tried
this so that I can add more color guys
you know 70% of women don't know how to
dress them
but we think it's true
today yeah I like the different textures
I'm not Ivan I got learned that too yeah
[ __ ] like that you really got to check
it out so there's no subscription
required you can pick between automatic
shipments or you get new pieces on
demand and shipping exchanges and
returns are always free so get started
today at stitch fix calm slash b tch and
get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box that stitch fix
calm slash b tch stitch fix calm /bj
don't be that 70% the 30
speaking of 30 did you ever lie via Waga
I was I couldn't wait to get to 30
because they look like they were having
so much fun I'm like they get to just
drink Cosmopolitan's and like go
shopping have cool style and they have
like a group of girlfriends that can
[ __ ] with and guess what that happened
we got a group of girlfriends
I think I think 30 is I'm so ready like
think of it this way everyone's like
okay the good ages are like 16 17 and
then like 20 through like 23 and then
like 24 to 29 is just a boy wait like oh
I have so much fun during that time why
it was such a void for me it was like
what am I doing with my life I was like
broke like all the time I think a lot of
people feel like that yeah like there's
for me like your late 20s is like
sorting out everything that you just
learned over the last 25 years and
trying to solidify it yeah we should do
an episode on on that sort of Avenue 20s
and oh yeah 20 the thing for me was I
like everyone else in the well almost
everyone else in the group was in their
30s I was like yeah [ __ ] those old [ __ ]
near gonna see her twenties forever and
in the moment I turn 30 like Oh
those are young bucks over yeah that's a
competition that's that was you
[Applause]
Jeana I think that is for you
subconsciously and biologically because
your most fertile in your and so we
wanted to talk a little bit about how
much your hormones change you from your
20s to your 30s did you do changes like
dude I [ __ ] I gained 20 pounds won a
[ __ ] pound okay
part of me is like maybe it was the
birth control I was like under a hundred
basically my whole life like 95 to 100
tops and I would always be like oh if I
was 105 I felt like I would be sexier
like I would have pain and like I might
be like a little picker in the hips I
felt that the reverse way I'm like if I
get down to 105 I might be 60 she
actually said sicker in the hips we
can't tell she has I thought that I
thought that I wanted to gain that
weight and then one day I literally just
I don't own a scale because I've always
been like super skinny but like one day
I got on the scale at David's house at
David Tso's house and like I was like
let me check and I was like I'm a
hundred and twenty pounds and I didn't
see it
that was a break for this scale in that
house dude wait did your clothes I
realized like I can't really wear crop
tops is about changing your in your
clothing do you know Bo I realized what
clothes I should have been wearing where
I like I was still wearing Hollister
like I'm 21 like and I was like wait I
look [ __ ] stupid like I need to dress
my age recently just I'm struggling with
that because yeah I noticed my entire
life I was always a size zero pants yeah
and then now almost
six and I'm like wait when did this how
did this happen like where did what and
I don't and I really don't know if it
was birth control or just getting older
like I can't because yeah I took it so
it coincided
I can't say but I actually I was gonna
like touch on this before like when you
guys were talking about the doctors and
stuff I think like one thing that's
really important to mention is like and
I don't know if you guys did this too I
went to my doctor's office and I was
like hey I need birth control what do
you recommend do not [ __ ] do that do
a little research talk to friends do
what you can because I had a doctor
recommend something to me and then I'm
like okay great I sit down for my exam
and put my feet in the little holder
things and I see the logo for the brand
she recommended to me which means the
doctor is sponsored by that brand so
when you fill up that prescription they
get money they may not tailor the
prescription to what you know exactly
what happened with me with that period
with the two periods a month exactly
like they will tailor it to what's going
to benefit them initially and it's not
out of malice it's all business and it's
you say recommend it they're gonna
recommend that one and it could be the
right one it could not be but it's
really important to try other birth
controls after a year of being on this
one I started getting migraines I was
having like after taking it I would get
very confused I couldn't like speak very
well and like after a few weeks of this
happening my boyfriend was like what the
[ __ ] and then come to find out I was
having like vascular issues from it I
could have had a blood clot I could have
like I'm really not sure but my doctor
did take me off it and then said I
cannot take any hormone based birth
control I could take like a copper IUD
but I couldn't take anything with
hormones and like I didn't know this
[ __ ] I didn't and I was getting confused
and slowed down like each night but I
didn't really realize it until my
boyfriend came over and I took I took my
birth control at 9 o'clock at night and
this was happening around 9:30 or 10:00
and I would just be like all right [ __ ]
go to bed and he was like hold the [ __ ]
up like what is going on here so like
you really for some reason you think
that birth control is not this like
dangerous or super super effective pill
watch your weight watch your like mental
state like if you're noticing attract
differences yeah like switch it up like
you have to you
yeah I've actually been off birth
control I wanted to talk about this
because I got a birth control because I
wanted to prep my body to have a baby
after getting married I was like okay
well we'll probably have babies in the
next couple years I didn't know I didn't
want to get off birth control cuz I
liked all the effects and when I got off
that I was like really shocked to find
that my face even changes chilly yeah
like this like fat down here was never
there when I was on my face is getting
rounder and I'm like yeah write it on a
scale and I got wait at the gynecologist
office cuz you know they wait you at the
doctor's office and I thought their
skull was [ __ ] broke I was like
that's not my weight cuz I still thought
like I wore the same size pants still
aim like it was just weird and yeah I
hit 150 which is the highest I've ever
been but for me it was a little
different story because in high school I
gained weight after puberty I got to be
like really chubby was like pretty big
for my frame for a while and that was
the most I've ever been then got on
birth control lost all that weight so
all of my twenties was like 120 ish and
uh 120 125 and then the most I'd ever
gotten to with age was like 130 135 and
then to see 150 on the scale was like
yeah the number is alarm yeah really
alarming and yeah I don't measure my
self-worth by that number but it was
definitely something that made me more
aware like whoa and took a second look
in the mirror to look at pictures went
back in my timeline the pictures on my
phone and I'm like wait I did change a
lot since I got off birth control you
don't realize this and nobody's gonna
tell you like nobody's gonna look at you
and be like oh yeah beause you look like
you gained 13 pounds like nobody's gonna
[ __ ] tell you that stress does a lot
to that to adds a lot to that too so not
only hormones but also stress but have
you guys ever tried I know we were
talking about this a little bit but the
temperature thing because that's what
I've been doing for the passage of years
and it really works if you want to take
some rod dick but you don't want to be
on any sort of birth control is this an
ad no the exact same thing that you do
when you you're trying to get pregnant
but Nicki uses it to not get pregnant
yeah she was telling me like I've got so
confused I was like wait you've done
this for
twenty three cycles and you still having
unpregnant she's like no I'm doing it to
not get pregnant I'm like oh yeah
so I wanted to regulate my body first
before we were trying to we would try to
get pregnant so you take your
temperature first thing when you wake up
before you get out of bed before you
move around at all you're like still
lying in bed you get it you take your
temperature under your tongue it gives
you a read you input you put it into
your app like so there's a few different
companies that do it I use natural
cycles but that's not sponsored but
there's a lot of different companies
that do this you put it into your app
and it can tell by the way your
temperature fluctuates where you are in
your ovulation cycle and then you even
take LH tests is what they're called
where it can tell if you're gonna
ovulate within the next 48 hours and it
kind of predicts what days you should
take those tests on so it can get a more
accurate read and then it gets down to
the day where it can predict your cycle
and and whether or not regular and if
your irregular you should check that out
and stuff they're like see you why or
talk to your doctor about it but I got
regular right away and my cycles 28 days
almost to the tee every single time and
and it's good to know so like it'll give
you red dais or green days depending on
if you're trying to get pregnant or that
like [ __ ] or don't [ __ ] yes Wow it's
like wear a condom or don't wear a
condom it's crazy I just take dick and
pray that I don't get pregnant okay take
a break yeah big embrace whatever been
doing now that you took out there yeah
we used condoms are the first time in
our entire relationship within the past
year since that two years since I've
been on this and I hated it at first but
now I kind of like pretend that I'm just
[ __ ] a stranger only use a condom
with with like strangers before that not
strangers but like guys that I wasn't
serious about dating that is like a
hookup and so now it's like oh I'm gonna
hook up with somebody I got on my breath
and chill and then we used condoms for
the first time and like when you pull it
out really into like and obviously right
you [ __ ] knew like a teenager
weird strangest [ __ ] and then like and
then I remember doing my my my usual
thing when I was younger and I used
condoms after he comes I would take the
condom fill it up with water and make
sure there's no leaks and we all right
we're good
like I do that I used to do that oh my
god I would do that just for fun I cared
just cuz it actually sounds funsies yeah
I like feeling that up me and like all
right let's see of segues Jeana we
wanted to touch a little bit on vaginal
health because yeah I dude was saying
beforehand I don't even know I thought I
read I had read about you know you
shouldn't do she should just yeah use
water and coward it's a personal
experience right growing up in a very
strict Vietnamese conservative household
we were never taught about vaginal
health and whatever it was taught in
school elementary and middle school is
very minimal yeah so like it was almost
like a taboo subject so I never knew how
to take care of myself down there right
like for instance at one point my
stepmom instead of making me do SH she
would get like this big bucket of water
pour in the douche vinegary mixture and
just let me make me sit on it
what yeah are you yeah I was like 10
what she's like oh yeah but yes it like
Vietnamese women like we have to keep
ourselves clean down there and that's
what she would do and I'm like okay I
guess like I didn't know anything and
yeah I think about it I was like I want
to call her and be like you're [ __ ]
dumb but you know like so it just none
of it made sense and I didn't know
anything about it and actually for the
longest time I had a vaginal bacteria
whatever like it's like a bacterial
infection which you can get literally by
anything if you wear the wrong type of
fabric if you don't drink it of water if
you abuse probably you can get BV from
an eye you know or like Oh bacteria yeah
yeah or like if you like on your period
you get it or if you take antibiotics
you'll just have an infection like yeah
vaginas are so fickle it's like their
own ecosystem that is just like anything
can [ __ ]
right so for the longest time I had that
and I thought that was normal like no
like every few week what what are the
symptoms of it so every few weeks like
my vagina smells really strange like all
right I thought this was like normal
like I've heard about vaginas like
having minutes on a cycle or something
and then like I never went to doctor for
it because I was like okay this is
normal it didn't it sure anything's it
wasn't anything alarming and my
discharge was like thick like uber thick
and it was heavy it was like a yeast
infection almost almost yeah and it was
like heavy like I'm talking like heavy
panties dude and I thought this was
normally because I was never taught in
yeah right he teaches you that no one
ever says anything
yeah actually didn't know that discharge
was normal I thought something was wrong
with me yeah see like and then so I went
to Planned Parenthood once for like um
birth control no like Oh once last time
he had a pap smear and this is like
early 20s I'm like I never had one
actually and they check me out they're
like yo you have like a bacteria like BV
I was like oh [ __ ] and they put me on
meds and literally the week after I was
like like everything's it's gone it's
one my smells gone charged and that's a
shitty thing about like growing up with
a family that doesn't teach you these
things cuz you don't know I think most
families don't or they don't know
because no no one taught them and that's
what I think is so odd it's like
something that like this is your body
you should know about it you should know
how to take care of it you should know
all about that and why don't they teach
you it I actually had this thing when I
was a kid where my vagina would hurt all
the time like it hurt it was really
painful like to like outside like after
I peed it would hurt and after but no
like kind of like almost like a UTI yeah
and I am actually more prone to getting
UTIs it's I don't know if its genetic or
whatever but some people I was wrong
younger and so when I was younger the
doctor had put me on acidophilus because
they couldn't figure it out it wasn't a
yeast infection it wasn't a UTI and so
he put me on acidophilus which is
actually like a probiotic
it's like strains of good bacteria that
because it's all like bacterial down
there right and that was the thing that
like cleared it up and also I wasn't
allowed to take any
baths with perfumes in the soap because
they thought that that might
also be area too irritating it but
that's my parents were going crazy
trying to figure out what the hell was
wrong with me because I would Jam crying
and pain because they ever figure it out
did that hell I think that was what it
was it was just like a bacterial
imbalance
dude like literally anything that's why
when I was like younger and I like I
can't tell which dudes are [ __ ]
stupid cuz they'll talk about girls like
yeah her [ __ ] smells like [ __ ] she
probably just took a bath and it [ __ ]
up her vagina you know yeah and people
just think like oh I mean like you're
dirty oh she's so dirty her vagina
smells like blood she probably [ __ ] a
bunch of dudes or maybe she wore silk
panties that day yeah you know so it's
like it's it's it's so like people don't
understand vaginas are so sensitive it
sucks like sex with a new partner you
get a UTI also I learned that after sex
you should pee and then also take a warm
take like some toilet paper or like a
warm rat like warm water on a rag and um
like basically like wipe that area just
you know that there's nothing that gets
caught up and gives you a UTI the least
you could do it look pee after sex yeah
go pan and masturbation you should pee
after masturbation too mmm because you
don't know what's on your hands mm-hmm
yeah that's that's fair Oh another one
another thing if you have like this is
like I feel like there's so many really
common things okay UTI pee after sex BV
go get a just an antibiotic it clears up
after like a week they're lovely scary
the scary thing about antibiotics too is
antibiotics kill like all of it all of
it yeah good get a yeast infection for
that so what's helping you can also
cause even more issues and the thing is
antibiotics make birth control work a
little bit less yeah so like all your
gut health yeah I recently got SIBO
which is an intestinal bacterial
overgrowth from taking antibiotics for
my UTI
oh my god yeah it's [ __ ] up yeah
and no one tells you this [ __ ] exactly I
still dream all time having a vagina is
it's like having a little baby that's
gotta [ __ ] take care of all the time
[ __ ] is like trying to get sick as
much as party be the best friend yeah
that's my best friend yeah right so yeah
if you if you have like BV or something
if you go to the doctor exactly like
Gina said ask them for I think it's I
think it's called like fluconazole or
something every doctor you just made
that up
single pill yeah I think I think that's
what it's called it's like a single pill
for yeast infections ask them after this
you know bacterial thing I need this
pill to to follow up they will 100% give
it to you and you just have to like ask
for it if you have a yeast infection
don't have sex with a guy he can get it
to ya and he will have no symptoms but
winds up happening is you give him that
yeast infection he has no symptoms you
get rid of yours then you have sex again
and he gives it back to you no guys it's
the gift that just given the shitty
thing is whether it comes to a yeast
infection sometimes it makes your veg
the skin on your your vagina and
everything around it super thin so
literally has ever had literally when
you're wiping it rips a little bit and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts and then leaves
like little tears all over your vagina I
didn't even know is a yeast infection
but I did take Monistat and yes that was
like it's like a cream it's not a pill
yeah this [ __ ] is so complicated yeah
cuz oh god be nice to us you guys what
is up man like everything can go wrong
and then so yeah like if if you have an
infection it makes the skin so thin like
it would rip while I'm wiping it'll rip
if I'm like spread my legs a bit like
when I'm walking or something that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks so please be nice to us oh
and going through [ __ ] oh you're talking
about silk panties I didn't know that
like not having 100% cotton underwear
can contribute to a UTI or you and all
that stuff bath bombs bath moms that's
why I stopped using them because I used
to love those the perfume water those
feminine soap thing is that that works
for me I like it I know that's a douche
like the soap just wash with me nyah
yeah cuz what I cure a swash alright I
don't know
so those but from what I've heard is
that you should not use that at all cuz
then like what you're saying do you know
how it [ __ ] up your florist summer's
eve is what it is that's what I heard
about douching to like so you not
supposed to do so yeah all right yeah do
do guys have to do any like intricate
thing like they have to dip their balls
no but they do might clean under their
foreskin yeah is that like a daily thing
like I mean Chris Magna hood yeah you
should wash your dick yeah is was my
dick my favorite is when I suck his dick
after he puts on like clean underwear
and it just tastes like a little bit
while G determined man that eats real
clean that's really nice I use some like
manly soap that I'm like ooh there's a
man so so there is a dick so dude I'm
just saying no Gina you're so right like
a freshly washed penis is like it's it's
like incredible yeah I think if it's not
freshly washed I don't do it yeah I mean
I'll take it like an 8 or 9 hour workday
but like it's not like we got to pick
and choose in high school he just kind
of pulled it out you didn't know what
his schedule was relationship down I
think I got too used to it like I got
spoiled now like yeah I need that clean
dick well a lot of guys wash their dick
in the sink - that's fine yeah which is
like considerate yeah oh by the way for
those of you who don't know this ladies
when you're wiping please wipe from
front to back
oh yeah I did not know that no I'm just
you know I didn't know and that was like
my vagina heard a lot that was one of
the things a doctor oh because no one
taught me how to wait yeah for sure you
know if no one kid good I was like oh
and my mom was like hey what the [ __ ]
and I still actually remember her
yelling at me about that and like yeah I
mean I don't think you think of it like
it's kid you're just like yeah much ya
know and I've met like adults like when
I say that they don't admit that they
don't know but they just look shocked
like yeah
yeah so please wipe from front to back
otherwise you're tracking [ __ ] stains
into your vagina that's why I was really
happy that I had a boy because it was so
easy to clean his nightmare I just go
from back I mean his balls are mm-hmm
it's fine
but eyeballs out dude baby bunny balls
but if I have a girl like when I think
about and Cristina dealing with Leia I'm
like isn't it a payment money like why
didn't the villains like you have to lay
the baby down and you're lifting up the
butt and like it's just it's harder yeah
yeah I feel like I'm gonna be such a bad
mom if I have a girl I mean I ah [ __ ]
she'll learn like that was what happened
to me you know what though I have a
question yeah when are you guys planning
on having are you doing to me everyone
oh [ __ ] can we go down the line baby's
coming maybe like cut honestly I'm
[ __ ] cute would we be though yeah
like you know I mean like when we're
pregnant together oh god I am actually
[ __ ] terrified of childbirth like I
was telling you before I follow those
medical instagrams where it's like I can
see people getting sawed in half but why
did you why would you follow that why I
totally dig stuff like that look like
surgeries I'm not like totally fine but
there is times when I accidentally
accidentally scroll and I'll see like a
baby crowning and I throw my [ __ ]
phone
Oh childbirth scares the fuzzy section
because it wasn't even that bad even
that I don't wanna be pretty crazy I
don't want to sit oh there's no girl is
we don't take out your intestine that's
above your uterus you only take out your
uterine they're okay they take out any
body part I think they take out the
uterus not a baby
I don't even I've read in some cases
where they literally had to remove some
[ __ ] Poots
it has child tries to figure out how she
had child bows they don't let you see
your paralyzed from the waist yeah oh
yeah all this pressure place your body
moving around and like like because
there's pressure going inside of your
body like sometimes they'll like move
your lung they feel like your intestines
at all your organs do not Nick they
don't part of the reason why though part
of the reason why I'm so damn terrified
of it is because I'll sit around and
listen to my aunts and my mom talking
about childbirth
do yourself a favor now and look up on
Google third-degree vaginal tear that's
when your vagina tears all the way to
your butthole it makes one hit big ass
oh they caught that animal Fisher I knew
a girlfriend anything I think like a
whole thing about childbirth yeah well
yeah she was not having a fun time
recovering from that and they're all
girl and then you have to wear like a
diaper for like weeks afterwards you're
bleeding my goal okay so I want to have
kids
I do like before I'm 35 but my goal is
to make enough money to have surrogates
mmm yeah about the whole like you don't
you want to miss out on like the
experience I'm good I'm like even though
I don't like how it's gonna mess up my
body like I feel like I've been really
training to get my body back in shape
and then now it's gonna get all babied
out again um I I feel like I want that
experience because you're put on this
earth to be a human and like have a
human experience and I just got more
experience all of it and so yeah that
whole creating a child inside of your
body I think that's [ __ ] crazy yeah
and I just want to know what I'm inside
of your butt I would have a test-tube
baby if I [ __ ] could like I'm not
about because it's like every time I ask
someone how their pregnancy is going
there's like everything [ __ ] hurts
and I can't eat anything and like I
asked I was like on a diet and
yes see that's why I don't do it [ __ ]
I'm not going to do this
so you're saying before 35 oh yeah you
Nikki probably like by the end of this
year I'm trying trying don't make that
pressure on me don't keep asking you
because like what if it takes a lot oh
they're so like you just let me be and
like let me take my time okay we're
gonna do as many episodes as possible
when Nikki's in her third trimester
really emotional and I'll be [ __ ] told
you sir one on my own and then maybe a
second a surrogate and then I'll have a
favorite based on like which one came
out of my body yeah yeah we're pretty
much on the same thing we're we're just
we're we are trying we're trying but we
were trying to get pregnant the same
time you're naughty oh we're not going
like hella aggressive like I think there
are other things we could be doing to
make this happen more aggressively but
we are not trying to do that or just
being like go with the flow and if it
happens cool if it doesn't cool but the
part that I mean it's really sweet cuz
everyone's really invested like you know
yeah follow us or like oh my gosh she's
glowing you should pregnant like oh she
looks fatter she's pregnant and I'm like
guys ya know gets really mean where
you're like I'm not even trying right
now like not pregnant yeah well I mean
we've technically are but like because
I'm not I end up getting self-conscious
gonna listen I know I can't wait to get
out and I just I'm not pregnant yet just
stop guys I'll let you know what he will
tell you I'm in the middle of baby fever
oh I feel like I can say this because my
boyfriend doesn't watch the show he's
not an Internet person he was doing a
show like it's not like he doesn't care
he just doesn't yeah that's how I know
I'm like grossly in love because I'm
like I would let you impregnate me you
know yeah like I mean I actually like I
think like a week or so ago I didn't
tell anyone this now I'm gonna tell the
whole podcast I like got home like a
little drunk one night and I still had a
glass of wine and I watch all videos of
people like with newborns and I was like
oh yeah
that's my baby - I'm like I like I
there's something that and I the thing
is though I don't I don't currently want
to have children I really want to get AI
want to buy a condo and B I want to get
my career together I want to be in a
really good spot with my career I do not
plan on having children until after 32
and I'm 27 now and I'm really for five
years whoa
I'm really firm on that okay but yeah
like I'm not planning on it anytime soon
but I'm honestly super excited and super
ready like to me though I think that
there is such a beautiful moment like if
you're like in a hospital room and like
you just have it your husband or
whatever's in the room and you like look
it comes out and you're like holy [ __ ]
we did this thing you made it's like
looks like it looks like you it looks
like us and it's gonna be like gosh so
we get to raise it it's gonna be I feel
like oh sweet there's still so many
things I want to do I okay first of all
I wanna get married and then I want to
travel the world more buy a house make a
[ __ ] ton of money and then I'll have a
baby you seen that movie idiocracy
mm-hmm all the people that want to do
that end up having kids later they can't
have them anymore and that's why the
world gets done oh yeah no that's that's
why I want to like preserve my eggs like
oh yeah I want to freeze my eggs and
then also it's really invasive tightly
oh is it yeah a lot of shots and
hormones your ovaries my best friend did
that and as for what Bo's is saying in
the hospital room that does not sound
fun to me like it's live in my mind like
I know the doctor is gonna ask if I were
to go through with this whole vaginal
birth thing the doctor is gonna ask my
man would you like to see the baby
coming out and I will grab him I'll be
like don't you [ __ ] dare look at my
vagina right now I want to preserve the
image of my beautiful [ __ ] in your mind
forever and I don't want you seeing this
[ __ ] crotch goblin come out me watch
it
hospital bed on the hospital bed and pop
out our child no land on his shirt
that's baby onesie like Gia like Bart
looked and I'm just like like Jesus at
the BART look [ __ ] that dude I want my
pink [ __ ] in your mind forever none of
you should coming out yeah my [ __ ]
speech Gina isn't it more beautiful when
he knows what it looks like at its
absolute worst and still loves you no
I'm not thinking that no I want my
vagina to be beautiful in his mind
forever yeah I've heard about stories of
men like not seeing their wife sexually
anymore because that was Elvis that
breaks my heart man after she had a baby
yeah because no I saw the child come out
and now it's like oh you're the mother
of my child you're no longer like a sex
creature and I'm like no I still gotta
be a sex creature sex crazy and I made a
pact that I will always be a sex
creature I don't care about this child
we have fights with our fake child
[ __ ] wants to come break us up
yeah oh my god that could be so cute
pregnant yeah and Steve's just like
standing over your baby just like [ __ ]
you kid best husband I'm sorry everybody
knows these are so bad yeah like can't
wait to pamper me and it's so cute like
any time I'm like I'm thirsty he'll just
get up and that's how we're having news
I mean lunch at JK news and then I was
asking like hey does anyone know where
there's a knife no one heard me and he
was across the room and he was like hey
TIFF what's up what do you need and I'm
like oh I'm just looking for a knife he
got up yeah looked around for a knife
for me and I'm like oh my gosh yeah he's
with his friends yeah member um we were
in the the other room over there were
their fridges and then like we were I
was grabbing a drink and he was grabbed
one too and then he was about to walk
out the door he goes wait Nicky might
really like this
he's really considerate thoughtful
he makes me feel like [ __ ] I'm like I
don't think about you now oh there's
free monsters okay madam that tequilla
yes true like oh like specific things
that I know he really likes Oh remember
but not things like oh he might like
this you know like we went to a beauty
event and then he's always like do you
guys want to get a drink I'll go get it
for you like yeah yeah as much of a
[ __ ] as he is on camera he's actually
really yeah he's like a sweetheart he's
very considerate I love that so imagine
me pregnant
imagine that kid like how much he's
gonna cry we question is it and I think
that this is something that comes with
age because at 20 I would've said
absolutely not don't care but now I'm
like yes is it attractive for you guys
when a guy is good with kids
oh dude carrying a baby throwing that
[ __ ] in the air and laughing I I'm
already my legs are spread at the park I
don't care [ __ ] we're in a family park
I'm pregnant now yeah she's hot oh I
love that yeah like when I like I saw my
boyfriend like playing with like his
cousins or whatever like they were like
playing with little toys do it [ __ ] I
was like well guys when that time comes
you gotta get off your birth control you
gotta start tracking your ovulation
cycles with the thermometer and I know
I'm gonna pay someone money will pay
someone but thank you so much for
listening I hope you enjoyed this
episode hope you learned a lot I hope
you maybe can teach us something in the
comments like let's fight your vagina
vagina vagina stories be nice to girls
this [ __ ] sucks man all this [ __ ] right
here birth control and vaginas be nice
to us a lot of maintenance we're going
through [ __ ] guys are like why does God
have to pay for tune or like we are
maintaining for China's right okay I'm
doing kegels while we eat we'll split
the bill with you cuz you're a little
[ __ ]
I think you're heading because this
[ __ ] is ramming the trees yeah and then
don't forget to check out our sponsors
Cara vitamin thank you so much for that
get 25% off your first care of order go
to take care of calm and enter b-tch and
then stitch and then stitch fixes let's
say that went through and we also want
to give us but for stitch fix for
sponsoring this episode if you want 25
percent off of your entire order use the
code b-tch and stitch fix comm slash b
tch thanks guys